حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
الاول من نوعه في بريطانيا منذ اكثر من 70
عاما
مراسم فخمه وفاتوره ضخمه بملايين
الدولارات
تقرير ام بي سي الامريكيه حفل تتويج
الملكه تشارلز قد يكلف بريطانيا اكثر من
145 مليون دولار
اما لجنه التنظيم فتقول ان تكلفه مراسم
التتويج تقدر ب 100 مليون جنيه
جزء كبير من التكلفه مخصص للعمليه الامنيه
منتقد حفل التتويج يرون ان تكلفه المراسم
الباذخه تاتي في ظل ازمه ارتفاع تكلفه
المعيشه
لكن لقصر باكنج هام راي اخر حفل التتويج
سيجلب مليار جنيه استرليني للاقتصاد
وهيئات تجاريه ترى ان الاحتفالات يمكن ان
تعود بمبلغ 350 مليون جنيه على قطاع
الترفيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات